-You look gorgeous.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-Thanks for playing
"Catchphrase."
I wanted to ask you --
I have a ton of questions.
Because last time
I believe we talked,
we discussed an RV trip.
-Oh, yeah, from New York to --
I sound so Canadian
all of a sudden.
-I know. You do.
-"Oh, yah! Oh, yah!
Oh, Gawd, yah! Oh, my Gawd."
-Soaree.
-"So soaree about that."
But, yes, we drove
from New York to Los Angeles.
-Oh, that's right.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-That's a major deal.
-Those are both cities. Yes.
-And was it as amazing
as you thought it would be?
-It was -- It was intense
'cause we did it in an RV
in, you know, 11 days.
-Yeah.
-So that was --
You know, we survived.
-[ Laughs ] "We survived."
-We survived.
-Was -- Is it just
great memories, though?
Is it like --
-Yeah. It is --
It is, now, reflecting...
-Yeah.
-...back upon it.
But we're a big, like,
road-trip family.
We drove up to Canada just
this past summer in August.
-Wow.
-And that was...
also enjoyable.
-Wow. That was really --
You really tried to sell that.
-You know, it -- it --
It's great. It's great.
I mean, this is the time
to be doing road trips, right?
-Of course.
-This is the time.
It's just that we decided to,
like, do 11 hours and 11 hours.
Like, a 20-hour journey.
-No.
And the kids are what age?
-They're 12 and 6.
-Yeah, okay, so that's --
-Yeah, young.
-Young, but still that's tough.
12 is, like, okay --
-Yeah, it's like
that would be the age
that you'd be rocking
the Gameboy
if your parents
let you have a Gameboy.
-Yeah.
-Which we don't.
-You don't have a Gameboy?
-No. No. No.
-What were you like
when you were 12?
-I -- Whoa. I was --
Gosh. So, so, so bad.
-You were a bad kid?
-I was a bad kid.
And so it's really weird
having a child who's sort of
approaching that age of,
like, doing bad things
and, like, she's an angel.
But I was like, you know --
I was really --
I was -- really cared about
what people thought about me.
And I was really grungy,
and I was, like, super
into Aerosmith music videos.
-Yeah. Really?
-I mean, who wasn't?
Let's be honest.
Alicia Silverstone
and Liv Tyler --
-The coolest kids in school.
-Like, the coolest --
-Oh, yeah.
-The coolest freaking kids.
-That was so interesting.
They were in,
like, three videos.
-I remember two.
It might have been more.
But it was --
"Crazy" was both of them.
And then "Crying" was this --
Sorry, "Cryin'".
It was an "N."
-"Cryin'". Oh, yeah.
-No "I-N-G." "Cryin'."
-And Alicia Silverstone
was, like, the star of that,
and she got, like,
broken up with,
and then she went on this,
like, journey and met this guy,
and then he stole her purse,
and she karate kicked him.
-Oh.
-It was wonderful.
And I loved it so --
I loved it so much that
I would, like, re-create it.
-In your bedroom or something?
-No, in our basement.
With a punching bag.
-Wow.
-'Cause I thought that that
move, that kick was so cool.
And I did it and I kicked it,
and I fell and I broke my elbow.
-[ Audience awws ]
-She's okay.
-Thank you.
-No. Everyone was like, "Aww."
-And it was --
This is, like, end of summer,
going back
into the seventh grade,
which is a big deal in Canada,
'cause you're, like, last year
of elementary school,
so you're like top dog.
And I was like,
"I cannot go to school
with a -- with a cast on."
-No. Of course not.
-I refused.
-Yeah.
-So my plan was...
I was not going to
tell my mother anything.
And I was just going to hide it.
And I got through it
for a couple of hours,
and then as soon
as she came home,
I was like -- [Sobbing]
"Mommy, I hurt myself."
-[ Laughter ]
-"I think I'm really hurt."
-See? Mom was there
for you, right?
She was fine.
-She was fine.
And we got a cast.
And it was fine.
I told everybody I hurt myself
skateboarding, to be cool.
-Yeah. You weren't kicking
a punching bag
pretending you're
Alicia Silverstone.
-No, I wasn't.
-No, of course not.
-No, I don't even know
what you're talking about.
-Cobie, I told you this
backstage,
but I'll say it again
in front of everybody.
"Impeachment."
I'm watching the show.
I think Beanie was on the show.
-mm-hmm.
-Who's amazing.
-Yes, yes.
-Plays Monica Lewinsky.
And it's about the Bill Clinton,
Monica Lewinsky,
the whole scandal.
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm watching it,
and Ann Coulter --
Someone's playing Ann Coulter
on the show.
-Right.
-And I go, "She's phenomenal.
She's great." It's you.
-It is, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yes, that was me.
-And you're phenomenal,
but I didn't even know
that you were in this.
And I go, "Wait. This is --"
I can't wait to talk to you
about this.
-Yeah.
-You dove right in.
This is unbelievable!
-I jumped in.
I jumped in, blond wig and all.
-Well, did you --
How did it work out?
When did you shoot this?
-Well, we shot it --
I shot my portion of it.
It's been a long-running series.
People have been working
really, really hard on it,
but I jumped in
like January of this year.
And I'm in about six episodes.
And it's been --
it's been super fun.
-You crush it.
-Thank you.
-How did you get the voice down
and everything?
Did you, like, study?
-Yeah, I listened to --
She wrote a lot of books.
-Yeah, she did.
And I listened to a lot of them
'cause she read them out loud.
So I listened to her voice,
and I --
There's a lot of interviews.
She does -- Girlfriend
likes to, like, interview.
-Yes. Of course.
-She puts herself out there.
-Yeah.
-And so she -- she likes
to put herself out there,
so you can watch a lot of
footage of her in those moments.
-Is there a word or something
that gets you
into the character?
-There was a few.
It sort of started with...
[As Coulter]
"American Republicans."
-"American."
-"The way --
She doesn't open her mouth
very wide.
And then it kind of
went to just a sound,
which would be like,
'Um, um. Um.'"
-Oh, my God. Wow.
-Yeah.
Because I think
she is always in a position
where she thinks she's smarter
than everybody else, you know?
And so it's just, like,
"She can't -- No.
Like, she just can't."
-"No. Just can't."
-"No."
-I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Cobie Smulders
In "Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
Take a look.
-You're boring.
That's the problem
with you Republicans.
-You're a Republican.
-Mnh. I'm a conservative.
You're all too nice.
What does that get you?
It -- It gets you Dole.
-What's wrong with Dole?
-Um...he lost?
Idiotic American females
couldn't wait
to re-elect their fat boyfriend.
-Be that as it may,
this case is all we have now.
-Right.
What would you like me to do?
-What you do best. Stir the pot.
-Uh, help us
get justice for Paula.
-Oh, this isn't about justice.
-Then what is it about?
-Impeachment, Jerome.
-There you go. Cobie Smulders.
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story"
airs Tuesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on FX.